the companies running gas stations  and setting those prices at the pump  bring down the price you are charging at  the pump to reflect the cost you are  paying for the product do it now  do it today  your customers the american people they  need relief now they need relief now so  gas stations just stop making a profit  biden has blamed everyone else already  he's blamed putin  he's blamed oil company ceos he's blamed  everybody but himself and his own stupid  policies and now he's blaming the poor  pakistani immigrant who runs your local  exxon mobil franchise do you know  what the average profit margin is for  gas stations on average  it's about 2 cents per gallon you're  looking at a profit margin of about 1.4  that is  way lower than the average profit margin  across all industries which is 7.7  percent